[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lonka guten Abend das
Ausmaß der Krise in Frankreich zeigt
sich auch daran dass Emanuel macron den
Staatsbesuch in Deutschland abgesagt hat
eigentlich hätte er morgen anreisen
sollen ein Staatsbesuch ist etwas
Besonderes zuletzt gab es den von einem
französischen Präsidenten vor 23 Jahren
Staatsbesuch das ist nicht einfach nur
Kanzleramt und Schloss Bellevue das
gibt's ja häufiger sondern ein riesen wo
Heim mehrere Tage lang rote Teppiche
Staatsbank hat militärische Ehren das
ganze diplomatische Protokoll wird
abgefeuert daraus wird noch nichts in
dieser exklusiven Lage muss ein
französischer Präsident in seinem Land
bleiben eine Abend berichtet aus Paris
Frankreich stellt sich auf eine neue
Nacht der Gewalt ein nael den Jungen der
von einem Polizisten erschossen wurde
haben sie heute in seiner Heimatstadt
und her beigesetzt doch bei den Unruhen
geht es nicht mehr nur um diesen Fall
was als Protest gegen Polizei Gewalt
begann ist längst eskaliert und trifft
das ganze Land
es ist eine Katastrophe ich habe so
etwas in meinem Leben nicht gesehen mir
fehlen die Worte ich habe doch auch eine
Familie zu versorgen was sollen wir nur
machen
ein Gefühl von Kontrollverlust auf das
die Regierung mit mehr Polizei mehr
Druck reagiert der Justizminister
beklagt die soziale Netzwerke würden die
Aggression weiter anheizen und dann
sichtlich aufgebracht ermahnt er die
Eltern
es ist unerträglich jetzt reicht's wir
ziehen alle Register und die Justiz wird
alle Randalierer strafrechtlich
verfolgen mit Härte systematisch wir
werden sie bei snapchat aufspüren und
dann den Eltern sagen passt auf eure
Kinder auf es ist nicht Aufgabe des
Staates die Kinder großzuziehen
tatsächlich sind die Randalierer sehr
jung zum Teil erst 13 oder 14 Jahre alt
viele Kinder haben bereits schulfrei und
sind dieser Tage ohne Beschäftigung nur
eine mögliche Erklärung für ein
vielschichtiges Problem und für den
Frust der sich nun entlädt
der Aufruf zur Ruhe bleibt ungehört es
kommt alles unkontrollierbar zusammen
Diskriminierung Rassismus dieses Gefühl
der Ungerechtigkeit die schlechte
Lebensqualität in den Siedlungen der
gnadenlose Leistungsdruck in der Schule
gegen den Beamten der geschossen hat
wird wegen Totschlags ermittelt die
Konflikte mit der Polizei eskalieren
immer öfter die wiederum beklagt eine
steigende Kriminalität und
Respektlosigkeit in den Vorstädten
was ich geändert hat ist wie sie
ausgerüstet sind und der Wille sogar zu
töten sie wollen wirklich Polizisten
töten und Feuerwehrleute sie greifen die
staatlichen Institutionen an
Kindergärten Schulen öffentliche
Verkehrsmittel und Behörden es gibt
keine Regeln mehr
mit Härte versucht der Staat nun die
Ordnung wiederherzustellen sie löst aber
nicht das eigentliche Problem auf den
angestauten Unmut in der Gesellschaft
wird Frankreich langfristig eine andere
Antwort finden müssen
und dann schalten wir noch nach Paris zu
Thomas Walde Thomas wie geht es jetzt im
Moment zu auf den Straßen
also in Paris ist der öffentliche
Personennahverkehr sehr stark
eingeschränkt worden wie im ganzen Land
zahlreiche Veranstaltungen sind abgesagt
öffentliche feiern abgesagt man will
weniger Menschen auf den Straßen haben
es sind auch weniger Menschen auf den
Straßen als sonst an vergleichbaren
Wochenenden gleichwohl werden aus
einigen Teilen des Landes wieder die
ersten Zusammenstöße und Krawalle
gemeldet in Marseille gab es die ersten
Festnahmen nach plünderungsversuchen in
Ports wurde ein Bürgermeisteramt
angegriffen auch in Paris gab es die
ersten Festnahmen in den vergangenen
Tagen ging es immer so gegen 23 Uhr
zwischen 23 und 0 Uhr so richtig los
darum würde ich den Zustand jetzt mal so
mitgespannte Unruhe beschreiben wie
versucht dann immer Manuel macron oder
das einzufangen also die Gemüter wieder
zu beruhigen
also dass er in Frankreich bleibt nicht
nach Deutschland fährt ist ja ein
Eingeständnis dass der elisee selbst mit
weiteren Krawallen und Ausschreitungen
rechnet und damit dass man mehr
Unternehmen müsse bislang muss man sagen
macht der Staat aber nur das was er die
vergangenen Tage gemacht hat ist werden
wieder 45.000 Polizisten heute Nacht ins
Land geschickt ein paar mehr nach
Marseille und nach Lyon weil es da
gestern Krawalle Grab das heißt man
reagiert auch heute wir haben es gesehen
Brot die Regierung wieder Eltern von
strafälligen Jugendlichen das hat sie
gestern mit ähnlichen Worten auch schon
gemacht ohne dass das viel genutzt hätte
was die Regierung bislang nicht macht
ist den Notstand auszurufen der
Sicherheitsbehörden mehr Befugnisse
geben würde das wäre ein Eingeständnis
aber das bisherigen Scheiterns das
scheut die Regierung ganz offenbar und
sie müsste so eine Notstand ja auch mit
Ausgangssperren erst einmal durchsetzen
können also das schaut die Regierung
bislang bis langsam muss man sagen hat
sie keine wirklich angemessene Strategie
gefunden danke schön nach Paris Thomas
Walde
der erste juli ist in Hongkong Feiertag
am 1 Juli 1997 gab Großbritannien die
frühere Kronkolonie an China zurück
seitdem hielt die Hongkong und
Demokratie Bewegung traditionell am
ersten Juli Kundgebungen ab die immer
mehr zu protestdemos wurden je mehr
Chinas Staatsführung den Sonderstatus
von Kongs in Frage stellte und dort
immer restriktiver durchregiert
2019 gab es noch einmal
Massendemonstrationen einer lebendigen
aber auch zunehmend verzweifelten
Zivilgesellschaft im Jahr darauf ließ
Peking für Hongkong ein neues nationales
Sicherheitsgesetz in Hongkong sagen sie
das war der Todesstoß
das Besondere heute in Hongkong alles
sieht normal aus am Feiertag sind Demos
eigentlich Tradition der erste erste
juli ohne Corona Restriktion zeigt auch
ohne diese Ausrede ist vom Protest
nichts übrig
Journalist Tom grandi lebt seit 18
Jahren hier zusammen mit seinem Hund
Pixel erlebt er den Wandel der Stadt
hautnah
es gibt jetzt patriotische Erziehung vom
Kindergarten bis zur Uni Razzien in
Redaktionen Verhaftung von Journalisten
das gab so noch nie auch im Justizsystem
handverlesene Richter
kautionsbeschränkungen und eine
hundertprozentige verurteilungsrate nach
dem Sicherheitsgesetz
der Brite kann freier sprechen als viele
hier doch auch er wählt seine Worte
vorsichtig denn nach Pekings sogenanntem
Sicherheitsgesetz kann nahezu alles
bestraft werden was als Kritik an der
Kommunistischen Partei ausgelegt werden
kann
wo 2019 bis zu 2 Millionen Menschen
demonstrierten herrscht heute normales
Leben das liege nicht etwa daran dass
die Leute im Gefängnis sitzen das Land
verlassen haben oder Konsequenzen
fürchten sondern
ist die Regierung hat sich darauf
konzentriert die Wirtschaft anzukurbeln
sich der Welt zu öffnen und so das
einkommensproblem der Menschen zu lösen
sie haben keinen Grund mehr zu Rebellion
mit dem Sicherheitsgesetz habe das
nichts zu tun
es sieht nicht dazu die Demonstranten
loszuwerden sondern um recht Ordnung
Harmonie und Stabilität wieder
herzustellen
harmonisch und geordnet so feiert die
Politik Elite heute das von Hongkongs
Freiheitsrechten genauso wenig übrig ist
wie vom Versprechen ein Land zwei
Systeme
für Tom crandy der 2019 auch über die
Proteste berichtete haben die leeren
Straßen heute sehr wohl mit dem
Sicherheitsgesetz zu tun und damit dass
die roten Linien nicht klar sind was ist
noch erlaubt was nicht mehr als er vor
acht Jahren seine Nachrichten Webseite
gründete war das anders
das war hier eine Bastion der
Pressefreiheit und der freien
Meinungsäußerung in einer Region in der
es an diesen Bürgerrechten und
Freiheiten mangelt deshalb eröffneten so
viele Medienunternehmen hier Büros
inzwischen sind viele gegangen Tom
grandi und sein Team sind noch da in
China wird Ihre Webseite schon lange
zensiert sie hoffen dass die
Sonderverwaltungszone Hongkong zumindest
in diesem Punkt nicht so schnell zu
einer normalen chinesischen Stadt wird
und jetzt die Nachrichten von Heinz Wolf
spanien hat heute die
Ratspräsidentschaft der EU übernommen
und Ministerpräsident sanche setzte
heute auch gleich ein Zeichen der
weiteren Unterstützung für die Ukraine
er reiste nach Kiel zu einem Treffen mit
Präsident silenski sanche sicherte noch
einmal die Solidarität der EU zu
außerdem kündigte er zusätzliche
spanische Wirtschaftshilfen von 55
Millionen Euro an
in den Niederlanden hat König
Willem-Alexander bei einer Veranstaltung
zum 150 jahrestag der Abschaffung der
Sklaverei für das verübte Unrecht und
Verzeihung gebeten er stehe hier als
König und als Teil der Regierung und
bitte um Entschuldigung so will im
Alexander schätzungsweise 600.000
Menschen wurden versklavt im Auftrag
will im Alexanders war Ende 2022 eine
Untersuchung zur Rolle des Königshauses
während der Kolonialzeit begonnen worden
in Bremen steht sieben Wochen nach der
Bürgerschaftswahl die Neuauflage der
Rot-Grün roten Regierungskoalition vor
dem Abschluss
Landesparteitage von SPD und Grünen
billigten heute den ausgehandelten
Koalitionsvertrag die Links-
das europäische Weltraumteleskop Euklid
ist heute ins All gestartet an Bord
einer Falken 9 Rakete begann die 1,5
Millionen kilometerweite Reise bis zu
der Position von der aus das Teleskop
den Weltraum genauer erforschen und tief
in die Vergangenheit schauen soll ein
Ziel dabei mehr über die kosmischen
Phänomene dunkle Materie und dunkle
Energie herauszufinden
alle Sommer wieder startet die Tortur de
France diesmal ist es die 110 angesichts
der Union in Frankreich passt es
zufällig ganz gut dass sie diesmal nicht
in Frankreich startete sondern im
spanischen Bilbao und die ersten Etappen
durchs Baskenland gehen heute gleich
schlappe 182 km mit schwindelerregenden
Höhenmetern die es ab zu strampeln galt
Doris Kramer hat sich das angesehen
die Tour de France 2023 wird eine
hochgebirgsrundfahrt
55.000 Höhenmeter 8 Berg Etappen über
alle fünf Gebirgszüge Frankreichs ein
Streckenprofil wie gemacht für sie vor
Jahresende Jonas single-go aus Dänemark
im Gelb-Schwarzen Trikot und der
zweimalige Tour Sieger tadee pogaccia
aus Slowenien die Sieger der vergangenen
drei Jahre auch in diesem Jahr wird es
das Duell werden
der grandepar der Tourauftakt zum ersten
Mal seit 1992 im Baskenland Start und
Ziel die Altstadt von Bilbao früher
Industriestadt heute
Kulturmetropole und schon immer sind die
besten radsportverrückt
zehntausende an der Strecke sehen eine
intensive erste Tour-Etappe über 182 km
und 3.300 Höhenmeter Georg Zimmermann in
neongelb einer von sieben deutschen
spurtet an der Quote Vivaro dem höchsten
Berg des Tages ums Berg Trikot doch sein
antritt zu spät
von der Kurve mein Taucher hat mir
angezeigt dass es noch 300 Meter bergauf
geht aber weil das die zielwertung wird
nie immer genau an der höchsten Stelle
abgenommen von daher doof gelaufen auf
der Abfahrt vom vivoro dieser Sturz für
Enric Maas Sieger der Spanien Rundfahrt
geht's nicht mehr weiter der
Mallorquiner muss aufgeben 10 km vor dem
Ziel der Tote Peak bei bis zu 20%
Steigung fällt das Fahrer fällt
auseinander die Tour Favoriten
puratscher und winglegau souverän und
als erste oben
die Abfahrt vom letzten Berg nutzen die
Zwillingsbrüder Adam und Simon Yates und
setzen sich ab bei Geburt war der wenige
Minuten älteres Simon schnelle in Bilbao
ist es Adam erster tour-etappensieg für
den Briten im Alter von 30 Jahren und
erstmals im gelben Trikot
Edin jetzt Teamkollege pogatscha wird
Dritter nimmt Konkurrent 4 Sekunden ab
Immanuel Buchmann als bester Deutscher
ist 24
mit Sport geht's auch noch mal weiter ja
die deutsche dressurmannschaft ist beim
CHIO in Aachen auf der ersten Platz
geritten und in der Einzelwertung gewann
die zweimalige Olympiasiegerin Jessica
von Bredo wendel
ein Lob für der Lehrer nach einem
perfekten Tag beim größten Reitturnier
der Welt im Dressurviereck von Aachen
gelingt Jessica von Bredow Werndl auf
ihrer Stute eine Prüfung voller Anmut
und Grazia trotz kleiner Fehler
81,021 Punkte genügen den beiden im
Grand Prix Spezial zum Sieg vor der
Britin Charlotte Bücher da und Nana
Scott mehr als aus Dänemark ich bin
total dankbar ich habe es heute ein
bisschen spannender gemacht als am
ersten Tag weil ich zwei sehr teure
Fehler mit eingebaut habe aber der
Lehrer gegen fantastisch auch sind die
Rotenburger mit Handy Isabel Wert auf
Quantas und Frederick wandres mit
Bluetooth überzeugen sie sichern sich
mit Jessica von Bredow Werndl und der
Lehrer den begehrten Sieg im Nationen
Preis
und morgen ab 16 Uhr senden wir live aus
Aachen dann den Großen Preis der
Springreiterinnen und Springreiter
die Formel 1 ist an diesem Wochenende in
Spielberg in Österreich das
Sprint-Rennen heute hat Weltmeister Max
Verstappen gewonnen vor sericho Peres
und Carlos Seins und jetzt die
Lottozahlen dieses samstags sie lauten
wie immer ohne Gewähr 13 18 24 27 38 43
Superzahl 3 und weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF
Text auf Seite 556
noch die Wetteraussichten morgen ziehen
ganz im Norden Schauer ostwärts auch in
der Mitte und im Süden gibt es
Regengüsse oft ist es sonnig an den
küstenweht der Wind stark in Bönen
stürmisch und West 18 bis 26 Grad in den
nächsten Tagen ziehen wiederholschau und
Gewitter durchhaber auch längere sonnige
Abschnitte hier sehen Sie es auch auf
der Karte die sind auch dabei es bleibt
windig mit Temperaturen zwischen 18 und
26 Grad
weiter und wir melden uns dann morgen
wieder auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]